bonjour et bienvenue sur 9 7 4 télé dans
votre émission vivre ensemble consacré
aujourd'hui au dispositif pass loisirs
dispositif volontariste jeudi du
département à mes côtés valérie miranda
gestionnaire du pass loisirs au
département monsieur lambert
bénéficiaires du dispositif et monsieur
françois acquier partenaires du pass
loisirs le pass loisirs est un
dispositif qui a été créée en 2003 mais
un bilan des dites nous dans quel but
alors il s'agit de favoriser l'accès aux
loisirs des personnes porteuses de
handicap en leur permettant de pratiquer
des activités sportives loisirs
culturels alors comment se présente ce
dispositif expliquez-nous un peu le
dispositif est une aide financière de 2
170 euros par an versés sous forme de
chèque aux personnes porteuses de
handicap et chaque bénéficiaire reçoit
donc dans l'année de chéquier de 40
perdant 2 carnets de 27 chéquier d'une
valeur de 5 euros
j'ai alors dit nous pour les
accompagnateurs comment ça se passe de
la personne porteuse d'un handicap alors
le chez qui il est nominatif
il peut arriver dans certains cas où
la personne handicapée aura besoin
d'être accompagné et c'est dans ce cas
précis ou l'accompagnateur peut utiliser
les chèques alors vous monsieur lambert
qu'est-ce que vous pratiquez comme
activité avec le pass loisirs puis je
vais pas pourquoi un type d'usagé
d'accord vous aimez bien aller au cinéma
parc aquatique de saint gilles quoi
d'autre qu'est ce que vous faites
également d'autres tâches et je fais
tout au carrefour costumes et est ce que
ça vous a permis de rencontrer de
nouvelles personnes d'utiliser le pass
loisirs oui et ça vous a donné envie de
sortir plus souvent de chez vous oui oui
d'accord mais nous aimons tous pour moi
déclare déçu non ça je vais totalement
d'accord alors madame bien mandat quelle
est l'offre disponible pour le pass
loisirs actuellement nous mettons à
disposition des personnes handicapées
une liste de cent trente deux
prestataires affiliés sur toute l'île et
de nombreuses activités sont accessibles
alors dites nous un peu quelles sont les
activités qu'on peut pratiquer avec le
pass loisirs alors des activités de
loisirs sportifs culturels tels que le
cinéma sur toute l'île les visites de
musées sur toute l'île
les spectacles c'est tout dire oui
d'accord alors je me tourne vers vous
monsieur accueil vous êtes gérant de la
ferme pédagogique chantal et françois
alors c'est quoi une ferme pédagogique
expliquez-nous alors 8e pédagogique
c'est un endroit on regroupe nombre
d'espèces d'animaux de la ferme en
général et ce qui permet aussi aux
personnes de venir découvrir les animaux
au plus près
et assez souvent et arrêter les touches
et voilà d'accord qu'est ce qui vous a
poussé à devenir partenaire du pass
loisirs alors très sensible aux
personnes handicapées donc la ferme de
puissants son ouverture a eu cet accès
aux personnes handicapées donc les
fauteuils peuvent accéder à la ferme et
donc on a continué de plus en plus à
aménager et bas les personnes
handicapées eux mêmes ont demandé à
venir plus souvent à la ferme
donc ce qui nous permet ce qui nous
conforte surtout de notre avancée dans
ce domaine
donc vous avez procédé à des
aménagements spécifiques dans votre
structure
oui et ça vous a apporté un plus ça nous
apporte plus oui d'accord et ça permet
justement aux gens de sortir puisqu'ils
ont pas l'habitude de pouvoir sortir et
visiter un endroit on les animaux s'y
trouve avec un fauteuil et justement
quel est votre public
alors on a tout public depuis
les six mois à 99 ans que donc on est un
cran public très large
d'accord vous toucher également les
enfants à l'heure alors on touche
beaucoup les enfants c'est une grosse
base colère parce qu'on refait un petit
peu l'éducation sur les animaux et et
puis bien sûr les personnes handicapées
puisqu'on travaille avec des autistes
ce qui nous permet de d'ouvrir un petit
peu plus l'esprit de ses enfants
autistes et même les adultes aussi souci
voilà monsieur lambert vous irez faire
un tour chez monsieur al khair à sainte
anne
je m'appelle je lui dis ça j'ai 22 ans
et qu'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je vais sortir avec ma mère
au cinéma pour voir le petit france
grâce au pass loisirs comme plus de
13000 personnes porteuses d'un handicap
judiciaire bénéficient du dispositif
pass loisirs une aide de 270 euros par
an présenté sous forme de chéquier
initié par le département de la réunion
ce dispositif vise à favoriser l'accès
aux activités sportives culturelles ou
de loisirs g j'ai fait et l'isle adam
hélicoptère et ckoi grand bleu et les
bateaux jeu là un frais les cinémas
c'est une bonne chose pour le pot les
gens qui handicapée aussi ils peuvent
faire des trucs avec leurs parents et
tous là et c'est bien pour eux aussi
qu'est ce que vous en pensez bah c'est
parce que c'est très bien pour les gens
qui allaient difficulté donc c'est bien
pour il peut faire beaucoup d'activités
avec parce que moi même c'est pas de les
moyens les années cinéma tout le temps
quand blé ou les ragots tous à la grèce
a pas cela si je dis ça peut faire
participer à ça les familles et les
contente qu'elle se sen t bien qu'ils
volent les gens normal c'est pas comme
elle qui est tout le monde est là c'est
pas que les enfants qui avaient dit
qu'ils étaient où les gens quelles
difficultés mais il ya aussi d anormal
donc ce mélange est donc tout le monde
est pareil quoi grâce au chèque pasquasy
re judiciaire peut profiter de
nombreuses activités proposées par les
partenaires du dispositif sur toute
l'île aujourd'hui ce sera le cinéma qui
pense oui pourquoi celui-là
la basket et rencontre sa princesse
alors même miranda dites nous comment on
devient partenaire du pass loisirs alors
il suffit déjà de nous appeler en
contact avec nous on explique aux gens
au téléphone la démarche très simple un
courrier de première demande en objet
une demande d'affiliation et dans le
courrier d'expliquer de décrire leurs
activités d'accor et de nous adresser au
service affiliation dupas soisy est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire quelles sont
les activités les plus plébiscitées par
nos bénéficiaires lors des activités
c'est que ce cinéma
ah oui je sais c'est mal éventuellement
les pins aquatique d'accord alors
actuellement plus de 14000 personnes
porteuses de handicap bénéficie du pass
loisirs si vous aussi vous êtes
intéressés alors je vous propose de voir
tout de suite les modalités pratiques
avec madame gironde
si vous êtes référencé à la mdph maison
départementale de la personne handicapée
comme personnes porteuses de handicap
vous pouvez venir nous voir à la dpa ph
cellule parce 26 avenue de la victoire
97 488 sa denis cedex pour une première
inscription ou prendre contact avec nous
au numéro suivant au 02 62 90 37 90 ou
par mail à l'adresse passe @ cg974 point
fr ensuite nous vous transmettrons un
dossier à remplir et à le retourner à
l'une des adresses que je vous inspire
notre émission s'achève je remercie nos
invités et je vous donne rendez vous
dans notre prochaine émission vivre
ensemble sur 9 7 4 télé à très bientôt
à